a great performance can leave a
permanent impression on moviegoers then
again bad acting can leave a similarly
permanent impression but for very
different reasons over the years we've
seen plenty of awful acting and these
scenes represent some of the very worst
here are some of our favorite poorly
acted movie scenes power of law of all
the ridiculous scenes in the Sylvester
Stallone starring dystopian disaster
Judge Dredd none play out quite as badly
as the long-awaited confrontation
between Judge Dredd and his brother Rico
at the end of the movie what begins is a
slow-burning war of words quickly
escalates to the point where Stallone
and Armand Assante forget how to
pronounce basic English not like
Stallone has great grasp of English to
begin with what kind of places pretty
much any scene from showgirls is bad
enough to make this list but the one
that always sticks out as being the very
worst happens to be toward the beginning
of the movie when Nomi meets her future
roommate Molly for the first time as we
saw on Saved by the Bell
elizabeth berkley tends to crank each
line up to 11 berkeley might have been
channeling that very scary moment when
performing in this scene when she
vigorously files her nails violently
stabs her beverage and pours ketchup
over french fries as if she's
auditioning for a commercial about anger
management
eventually Molly asked for no mise from
and that's when things get really
dramatic
Becky's from where Becky's different
places it's a pretty extreme reaction
huh but maybe it's not the light of
questioning that's got her upset maybe
she just doesn't have the right stacks
feeling burned Nicholas Cage's
performance in the wicker man is so bad
people who haven't even seen the movie
were able to quote infamous lines like
this one now why in the hell would you
let them do a sick thing like that
things get particularly loopy when cages
character a policeman who interrogate
sag rip and neo-pagans after his
daughter goes missing discovers a burned
doll he believes belong to his daughter
that's when we get a glimpse into the
Nicolas Cage school of interrogation
Anakin's beach blues even after we got
the force awakens the ill-advised Star
Wars prequels continued to linger
painfully in fans souls like some kind
of cosmic penance gods it is and few
scenes are as hatefully remembered as
Hayden Christensen's chat with Padme and
attack of the clones about that's right
Sam because when you got a movie with
lightsabers and an army of clones
marching around with laser guns and
galactic stability hangs in the balance
we need to stop and talk about how
annoying it is when Sam gets in your
crack I don't like sound it's coarse
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere over a decade later people
are still joking about it talk about a
scene that has legs
ooh just realizing about that hole has
legs thing really insensitive sorry
about that
what's happening what do you do when you
try to calm down a crazy lady you deny
your accusations with the convictions
and believability of a four year old boy
at least that was Mark Wahlberg's plan
during his confrontation with Betty
Buckley and then night Shyamalan as the
happening planning on stealing something
no ma'am we're not plan on murdering me
in my sleep
what No even Wahlberg himself admitted
the movie sucked during the press
conference for the fight or two years
later you can't blame me for wanting to
play a science teacher you know I wasn't
playing a cop or a crook Mark Wahlberg
doing a bad job of acting in a
forgettable movie what no don't be the
trolls picture the scenario you realize
you're about to be eaten alive by trolls
what do you do what do you say maybe you
take a cue from Arnold the nerdy
teenager in troll 2 and do something
like this
alas it was too late to save Arnold what
no sorry mark Whalberg there was nothing
we could do
of course the room skip to any random
scene in the room Tommy Wiseau's writing
acting and directing debut from 2003 and
it's painfully bad in the very best way
did not hit her did not oh hi mark
this film is so poorly constructed that
it's been dubbed the Citizen Kane of bad
movies making it hard to narrow it down
to just one laughable scene but the most
popular best of the worst moment came
when was so stuck 'old that jonny
confronts his thought to be cheating
fiance lisa in this now iconic exchange
believe it or not according to what so
is co-star and friend Greg Sestero the
moment was inspired by James Dean who
uttered a virtually identical line and
rebel without a cause who performed
better we think it's time for Tommy to
celebrate do you want me to order a
pizza whatever I don't care I already
ordered a pizza you think about
everything thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
scenes you think we should have had on
this list